[Aplausos]
em 2014 eu encerrei uma longa trajetória
profissional de aparente sucesso
a empresa que eu tinha criado 15 anos
antes e que tinha se tornado um ícone na
sua área de atuação havia se tornado tão
pesada que parecia mais um fardo do que
um projeto de vida que era o que tinha
feito ela nascer naquele momento ficou
muito claro que para trazer mais vida
pra própria vida
eu ia precisar abrir um novo capítulo eu
comprei as minhas obrigações com o
mercado naquele último ano atende os
meus clientes diz fiz as relações com os
colaboradores dentro de toda a
legalidade
encerrei uma sociedade fechei as portas
e aos 45 anos
eu decidi me lançar na maior e mais
arriscada aventura da minha vida eu
decidir que de alguma forma
depois de ter vivido um belo propósito
profissional eu devia mim mesma
a obrigação de novamente encontrar o
sentido no trabalho
eu estabeleci alguns poucos contratos de
consultoria suficientes pra garantir a
minha sobrevivência e também para
permitir que eu tivesse tempo e quatro
ou cinco meses depois de fechar as
portas da empresa eu estava nos estados
unidos uma experimentação
eu caí quase que de pára quedas dentro
do congresso mundial de psicologia
positiva indo atrás do tema principal
que é a felicidade
aquele congresso 2015
forjou
um novo capítulo da história na minha
vida da própria história da minha vida e
me trouxe a posição na qual eu me
encontro hoje como o pesquisador
acadêmica e professora de psicologia
positiva a psicologia positiva é a
ciência que estuda a felicidade e numa
dessas brincadeiras da vida ou
sincronicidade como um chamaria a a
psicologia positiva disse pra gente que
felicidade existe sobre dois grandes
pilares de um lado viver mais emoções
positivas do que negativas
a gente não nega a existência das
emoções negativas elas são necessárias
para a sobrevivência elas protegem a
vida e nos fazem crescer mas precisamos
ter mais emoções positivas do que
negativas se quisermos aumentar nossa
reserva de felicidade e isso está nas
nossas mãos
o outro pilar é olhar para a própria
vida a vida que cada um de vocês está
vivendo hoje
nesta data e ter a percepção de que ela
tal qual é tem sentido e vale a pena
isso se chama propósito e também está
nas nossas mãos
é muito fácil compreender o quanto o
tema propósito tem e meus aderência com
o ser humano e ovacionou harare no livro
21 lições para o século 21 capítulos
sentido diz o seguinte quero algo que
explique o meu papel
nesta aventura cósmica algo que faça com
que pertença a algo ainda maior e que dê
sentido das minhas escolhas e para as
minhas experiências
é fácil entender isso
imagine que agora cada um de nós aqui é
um ser
que não sabe de onde veio
não tem certeza para onde vai e que está
vivendo na superfície de um planeta que
flutua no universo sem fim
é muito difícil viver essa experiência
sem uma âncora e essa âncora a gente
pode chamar de propósito um dos maiores
pensadores que não só investigou como
viveu a há a identificação do propósito
na essência se chama victor frankl um
neuro psiquiatra austríaco que por ser
judeu acabou sendo mandado para dois dos
piores campos de concentração do
holocausto da raw e auschwitz o jovem
professor médico
iniciando uma carreira uma carreira como
pesquisador victor frankl mantém uma
imagem mente eu vou sair daqui e vou
reencontrar a minha esposa grávida
meu pai à minha mãe e os meus irmãos
passar do tempo ele chega a saber que a
esposa os pais e os irmãos perdão um dos
irmãos estavam mortos
e dentro daquilo que a gente jamais
seria capaz de sequer imaginar o que
seja ele busca ressignificar aquilo que
o mantinha vivo como pesquisador que já
era começa a observar dentro do campo de
concentração o comportamento dos seus
companheiros de desventura e ele percebe
ao longo do tempo que no dia que aquelas
pessoas o que uma pessoa não levantava
no toque de recolher de de levantar o
que não era absolutamente uma opção
fumava o último cigarro
ele sabia que existe uma grande chance
daquela pessoa naquele dia
sou konder e começa também identificar
aquelas pessoas que mantinham um forte
senso de sentido para uma vida que
possivelmente viria depois eram as
pessoas que conseguiram permanecer por
mais tempo firmes em meio a barbaridade
aquela pessoa que tinha um neto que
teria nascido e gostaria de conhecer
muitos intelectuais judeus estavam nos
campos de concentração
muitos tinham livros iniciados que iriam
terminar
muitos estavam desenvolvendo alguma
teoria uma pesquisa que queriam concluir
victor frankl nesse seu próprio processo
interno e externo como investigador
estabelece que um dia ele vai estar no
auditório como esse
contando com as pessoas da importância
do propósito do sentido de vida a partir
de certamente de princípios científicos
ele cria a logoterapia que é a terapia
existencial a partir da identificação do
sentido e se torna uma das grandes
mentes para que a gente conheça essa
força que é humano mas como trago isso
nosso direito a nossa vida como a gente
identifica
de fato o que é um propósito propósito
tem algumas características ea gente já
sabe quais são
primeiro ele nos motiva mesmo que não no
âmbito da consciência aquilo que nos faz
levantar numa segunda feira depois de um
fim de semana mais preguiçoso é aquilo
que faz a gente vê essa mania inteira
com intensidade sem necessariamente
esperar pelos 'estou ou pelo tem god
it's friday é aquilo que dá sentido para
as horas que a gente tem na vida simples
que a gente vive
ele
sentido para as nossas escolhas funciona
como um norte para as nossas decisões
ele dá sentido para os nossos
sacrifícios e ele tem duas
características muito importantes
ele vem de dentro então na verdade a
gente não busca o propósito a gente
detecta o propósito e ele não pode
beneficiar simplesmente a mim se for
isso é um projeto é uma meta um objetivo
é ótimo mas não é um propósito um
propósito precisa ter um impacto
sistêmico mesmo que num pequenino
sistema não importa o tamanho tem que ir
além de mim tem que me fazer perceber
que eu pertenço há algo maior
o propósito é também uma das quatro
necessidades psicológicas básicas e
universais
juntamente com autonomia e competência e
pertencimento
no âmbito do trabalho existe um
pesquisador chamado michael estiver é
hoje certamente maior cientista vivo
pesquisando o sentido da vida e
propósito da universidade do colorado
que nos mostra que não se trata de uma
idealização do propósito no trabalho a
gente precisa basicamente de três
aspectos para viver um propósito no
trabalho
a sensação de que o trabalho é legítimo
a percepção de que meus valores pessoais
não entram em conflito com os valores da
organização para a qual o trabalho e à
percepção de que aquilo que a
organização faz gera um impacto positivo
na sociedade lucro não é propósito há
pouco tempo nem chutar ele trouxe uma
capa emblemática amarela com uma única
frase muito pouco tempo é hora de
resgatar o capitalismo
a gente vai precisar reinventar o
capitalismo em letras menores abaixo vem
o seguinte frase o lucro é inegociável
ele precisa existir
mas nenhuma organização poderá se dar ao
luxo de existir sem servir a um
propósito maior
isso a gente tem visto no âmbito mundial
infelizmente tem visto também no brasil
o quanto organizações são capazes de
prosperar tendo um propósito maior que
move toda a sua força de trabalho
outra relevância em relação à proposta
de trabalho é o propósito reduz do
trabalho reduz os riscos para a
depressão
a depressão é a doença que deveria estar
em primeiro lugar em 2020 como aquela
que mais incapacitam para o trabalho e
infelizmente nós conseguimos antecipar
essa meta e ela já é a doença que mais
incapacitam para o trabalho no brasil e
no mundo
no brasil as empresas gastam 1 7% do que
investem em saúde ou despendem com saúde
por causa de pressão ea gente poderia ir
além do transtorno de ansiedade síndrome
de pânico síndrome de burn out e
suicídio
um a cada 40 segundos no mundo
o e martin mostra pra gente que
obviamente existe uma questão de
adoecimento fisiológico mas existe como
pano de fundo uma grande crise de
sentido
quando eu falo sobre proposta como eu tô
falando hoje com vocês é sempre comum
que depois as pessoas me perguntem
na prática o que eu posso fazer pra
perceber
meu propósito a gente pode falar de três
ideias muito simples intenção intenção
intenção de trazer mais vida própria
vida
a intenção não é maior
a fé é a maior força humana não é só uma
das forças humanas
foi com intenção que
mahatma gandhi martin luther king e
nelson mandela mudar o eixo da história
a partir a princípio de uma intenção uma
segunda proposta é a atenção educar a
própria atenção pra perceber o que de
fato faz sentido na sua vida
para onde vai a minha atenção
se eu não sei qual é o meu propósito
certamente a atenção a minha atenção vai
me contar porque a minha a minha meu
olhar será destinado aquilo que de certa
forma fala comigo ea terceira é explorar
explorar
eu agradeço o dia em que eu tive a
coragem de me inscrever num congresso
que eu mal sabia do que trataria porque
foi naquela experimentação e eu tive
algumas anteriores que eu encontrei um
trilho ao qual joseph campbell se
referencia referência como o trilho da
felicidade que sempre teve ali foi a
gente que não subir nele cinco anos se
passaram e eu cheguei no lugar que eu
jamais imaginaria chegar eu ensinando e
aprendendo felicidade estive em todos os
continentes ainda não na áfrica está no
meu radar eu fiz mais de 20 viagens
internacionais que tive a minha vida
profundamente transformada
mas não foi um mar de rosas dez meses
depois de fechar a empresa já a bordo do
meu propósito teve um diagnóstico de
câncer depois de um checape e o que eu
posso dizer para vocês é que aquele
câncer raro e conté cima o prognóstico
não foi capaz de tirar o meu equilíbrio
porque eu estava ancorada em uma visão
de algo maior e que muito mas muito além
de mim
e eu vejo no olhar do meu médico quando
ele vê os exames muito bons
ele sabe que a medicação funciona mas
ele lançou um olhar pra mim aquele olhar
de dúvida querendo entender o que existe
nessa pessoa nessa pessoa existe um
propósito
eu desejo a vocês a todos vocês que se
lembre de manter uma intenção de uma mãe
de manter uma intenção de trazer mais
vida pra própria vida de vocês de lançar
a atenção e de prestar a atenção à
própria atenção sustentar a qualidade de
presença no aqui e agora para entender o
que de fato faz sentido e não ter medo
de explorar
obrigado
[Aplausos]